and and Marcus apparently is repeating
so this this might be over soon we could
uh potentially we could just watch that
game being yeah I think yeah there there
we have it they are just signing the
scoresheets the game is over
so yeah well played to daniele because
he was eventually put under I think
serious pressure just to figure out
what's going on and to to keep the
position under control
but he managed quite well
he managed quite well and uh the end
result is a draw and Norville loses
up with a big score yeah they lose three
a three one there
uh with uh
Magnus making a draw
I think Hammer making a draw no Hammer
lost yeah
I I actually have to say I'm very very
happy for for Daniela because
he's my teammate in team Padova and uh I
know that he's so reliable I mean I
think playing on board one for for a
very long time for the Italian team
has Lily he gained a lot of experience
against very strong players and when we
went on to win the the European Club Cup
in 2019 then he was the one who beat
kovalev with the black pieces in the
decisive match against copia and uh yeah
it's a very very nice person and the
wonderful chess player as well so great
to see him hold his own against Magnus